as obvious as it sounds the Justice
Department's inspector general just
found the missing text between those two
FBI agents what did he do well he merely
took possession of the phones can you
imagine the FBI claimed over the weekend
it couldn't find the five months of text
between struck and page but it took the
inspector general just two days after
senators demanded the answers good for
him also breaking tonight Fox News can
now confirm that President Trump ordered
the firing of Special Counsel Robert
Muller last June but he backed down
after White House Counsel Don McGann and
others convinced him not to that news
was first reported by the New York Times
earlier tonight let's explore that in a
lot else with former Harvard Law prof
Alan Dershowitz in Miami in in Orlando
congressman Ron De Santis Republican
from Florida and here in studio my
friend attorney and Democratic
strategist Scott Bolden all right we
have a lot to get through I've got to do
together professor let's start with you
on this New York Times report that the
president wanted ax Muller and McGann
said can't do it you do it I'm out well
it just shows you that everybody should
listen to their lawyers whether you're
the President of the United States or
anybody else
McGann said what advice was very very
sound advice look the president has the
constitutional authority to fire anybody
in the executive branch the Supreme
Court has held that on the other hand it
would have been very unwise politically
and it would have sounded like an
admission of some kind of guilt he's so
much better off following his current
lawyer's advice as well which says look
be nice to Muller say you have nothing
to hide
be willing to sit down and be
interviewed by him under oath and you
have nothing to lose when you do it
under oath because it's just as much a
crime to lie not under oath is under
oath and respond to the questions and
try to wrap up the inquiry that is the
best advice he could possibly what he
said yesterday when he left for Davos
now I mean I'm fine with sitting down
under oath answering questions that's
the better tact I always said it would
have been a ridiculous idea I wouldn't
have fired call me when he did I would
have cleaned the whole into integrity
a huge mistake Scott I want to go with
you very quickly on this we moved to
text and go to the congressman Scott the
idea of firing Muller the New York Times
you can look at me now The Times is
going nuts to this president has the
constitutional prerogative and do it
he's he's a regular guy he's a
businessman
he's used to firing people when he
doesn't like them is this a big
bombshell in your eye it's a big
bombshell because it's Donald Trump the
idea that he followed his lawyer's
advice thank goodness for that
I'll have to give that GOP lawyer that
but but but the I did here's the bottom
line though and what's really behind
Donald Trump really thinks DOJ works for
him
he thinks everybody in the federal that
may work for him they really don't they
represent the people for the United
States he's maybe but he can't fire
someone legitimately who's investigating
them without turning this into a
constitutional crisis it's fundamentally
wrong it's not AG you're making a point
of politics in your I agree with you
pragmatically and appearance-wise it
would look terrible but as a
constitutional matter as professor
Dershowitz pointed out as the chief
executive officer of the country the
head of the executive branch he has the
authority to fire anyone he could fire
Monge works for you well pressure
Dershowitz you do expect and every
president expects some loyalty from the
people who work under him it means you
don't go off half-cocked on an issue if
he thinks the russia investigation is
ridiculous
he's going to express his frustration I
have no problem with that problem but I
have a problem but it's the problem with
the Constitution the framers made a
terrible mistake
by combining two offices together one
the adviser to the president and
injustice matter and the other the chief
prosecutor most other countries divide
those functions I think we covered that
issue let's move on to these the missing
text they were just they were discovered
a lot of people thought you had to go to
the NSA for these texts but they found
them including one interesting text in
particular struck an page discussed via
text how many personnel from DOJ and FBI
would be included in the Clinton
investigation and they said one more
thing she might be our next president
the last thing you need is us going in
there loaded for bear
do you think she's going to remember or
care that it was more DOJ than FBI
struck says agreed I called bill and
relayed what we discussed he agrees I
will email you and blank redacted same
does that indicate a more of a kid
gloves treatment to Hillary and that one
text or we make it too much of that Ron
well I think it does but you know that's
not the only thing we have I mean we
have the whole investigation and how it
was conducted and at all the inflection
points they were bending over backwards
not to make a case against Hillary
writing the memo two months before the
interview dur changing a grossly
negligent which is criminal culpability
to extreme carelessness so I think it's
yet one more data point that these two
folks and the FBI did have political
bias but I also think you know the FBI
said and the DOJ oh we can't find these
things it was just like the IRS with
Lois Lerner's emails they didn't even
really look for them and then here the
Inspector General gets him in the next
two days so I want to know who was
responsible for sending that response to
Congress saying that they were deleted
because that was not yeah
that's odd and also you know chip smoked
out I want to play this Adam Schiff
spoke out I guess it was earlier today
about what Republicans tactics are here
let's watch the Republicans many of them
are all too desperate to distract
attention from the Russia probe and try
to put the government on trial this has
been a strategy for quite some time now
and even when they have no basis to do
it it doesn't stop them from making the
most scandalous accusations against
these professionals at the FBI
yeah it's directed at the congressman
but let me just let me just say Chris
Matthews also said since when do
Republicans have such a problem with law
enforcement they could flip it on them
and say since when did liberals not have
concerns about the abuse of authority by
the law and for exactly right
thing is you know i i am i've military
background and law enforcement and i can
tell you the reason why i support law
enforcement and this is the same reason
why i'm upset about what i've seen
because that's not representative of law
enforcement these are people who were
not doing the job the way it's supposed
to be done and in order to have
confidence in this system if people are
not behaving properly if there was
abuses you need oversight over those and
people need to be held accountable to
just act like these agencies should be
able to go on with no oversight no
accountability i want to go to scott
there's no question this truck should
have recused himself he knew before
anybody else did about his own biases
and he should be fired now no person in
the FBI no justice department official
should not recuse themselves when
they've written those kinds of emails
those kinds of texts those kinds of
messages and his failure to recuse
himself from the investigation for me as
a fireable offense
he certainly has done that he said
what's bothersome about this is how
politics and the GOP and the House and
Senate have politicized and weaponized
this information that they're receiving
by a subpoena and then picking and
choosing parts of it and using it to
discredit DOJ and FBI it's wrong that's
why criminal investigations ought not be
commented on until they're complete and
the allegations against the Democrats or
DOJ and FBI it's so negative it's
unnecessary and inappropriate the only I
think the question we're gonna determine
is whether the FISA process was
weaponized to try to stop Trump from
becoming president after focus on that
will allow well we'll see in the full
context gentlemen great segments as
always